let's do a bunch more of these addition
problems so let's say i have nine
thousand three hundred and sixty seven
plus
two thousand four hundred and fifty nine
so we can do this the exact same way
we've done in the last few videos we
start in the ones place so you can even
think of it as the ones column so you're
going to add the seven ones plus the
nine ones so you have seven
plus nine which we hopefully know by now
is sixteen
so what we do is we write the six in the
ones place
and we carry the one so if this one
let me switch if this one is going to be
the same thing as that one
right there and this might look like a
little bit of a mystery or magic and the
whole reason we did that is that this is
the tens place and when you write
sixteen you have six ones and one ten if
you view this as money how would what's
the best way to get sixteen dollars in a
world where there weren't five dollar
bills we only had one dollar bills ten
dollar bills hundred dollar bills and so
on only only multiples of ten and we
don't have any five dollar bills in that
world you would represent sixteen as one
ten dollar bill
one ten dollar bill just like that and
then six one dollar bills
let me
so that's two one dollar bills
that's two more one dollar bills
and then
and so 16 is so the whole reason why i'm
drawing it this way or i'm even using
this analogy or drawing the dollar bills
is to show you what these places mean
when i say when i tell you
when i say that this right here is the
tens place
i'm essentially telling you how many ten
dollar bills do i have if i have sixteen
dollars and i'm doing it as i'm i'm i'm
doing it as efficiently as i can in the
world without five dollar bills i only
have ones tens and hundreds and thousand
dollar bills and so forth and this is
the ones
so when i write it this way i'm
literally telling you i have one ten
dollar bill and i have six one dollar
bills that's what sixteen dollars is and
so when i have seven plus nine is equal
to 16 i say that i have six one dollar
bills and i have one ten dollar bill and
i add that one ten dollar bill to
everything else and the ten space and
the tens place is essentially telling
you how many
that's the tens i'll write like i could
write it like that or i could write the
tens place that when i have 67 67 means
i have six ten dollar bills plus another
seven ones so that's six tens five tens
so i add up everything in the tens place
so one plus six plus five let me do that
in a new color
one plus six plus five is equal to one
plus six is seven seven plus five is
twelve so i write the 2
in the tens place because remember this
is 12
10 bills right because we're in the tens
place so i have 2 in the tens place and
then i put the 1 i carry this one right
here into the hundreds place because if
i have twelve ten dollar bills i have a
hundred and twenty dollars i have one
hundred dollar bill and i have two ten
dollar bills i'll i'll stop going to the
dollar bill analogy just so we can make
sure we understand the process but i
think you see how it how it works you
start at the right you add the two
numbers up if it's a two digit answer
you carry the the leftmost digit up to
the next column and you just keep doing
that so let's do this one right here 1
plus three is four let me write this
down in another color
one plus three plus four
one plus three is four plus four is
eight so one plus three plus four is 8.
nothing to carry it was a one-digit
number and then finally i have 9 plus 2
9 plus 2 that's equal to 11. so i write
the 1 down there i write this one and
then if there was anything left here i
would carry the the tens or or the the
other one the one in the tenths place in
11 i would carry it but there's nowhere
to carry it to so i write it down just
like that so
9367 plus 2459
is 11
826 and i just put that comma there
because it's easier for me to read let
me do a bunch more of these let's do a
really
really daunting problem let's do
something in the millions just so just
to show you that you can do any any
problem
so let's say we have two million three
hundred and forty nine thousand
and
fifteen let's throw a zero in there
right we have nothing in the hundreds
place there and i want to add that to
switch colors just for fun i want to add
that to
seven million
seven million let's put a zero there
fifteen thousand and nine hundred and
ninety let's add these two numbers this
seems like a hard problem but if we just
focus on each of the places i think
you'll find that it's not too bad so we
start off with 5 plus 9 5 plus 9 that's
equal to 14. write the four down here
carry the one then you go into the tens
place one plus one is two
two plus nine let me switch colors one
plus one is two two plus nine is eleven
carry the one
one now we're in the hundreds place
one plus zero is one
plus nine is ten
so we write the zero from the ten carry
the one let me switch colors again
one plus nine is ten
ten plus five is fifteen
fifteen now we're in the ten thousands
place
one plus four is five and five plus one
is six
and there's nothing to carry
now we're in the hundred thousands place
three we have nothing to carry so we
just have the three hundred thousand
plus zero hundred thousands well that's
just three hundred thousand and then
finally we're in the millions place two
million plus seven million is nine
million just like that so yeah this is a
super crazy number two million three
hundred forty nine thousand and fifteen
plus seven million fifteen thousand nine
hundred ninety nine just by keeping
track of our places and carrying the
two-digit numbers or the second digit in
the two-digit numbers as necessary we're
able to figure out that the answer is
nine million
three hundred and sixty-five thousand
and
fourteen so hopefully this gives you a
pretty good sense let me just do one
more just to really make sure that we we
really understand
how all of this carrying business works
so let's do
15 million
999 000
and one
plus
six million
eight hundred and eighty eight thousand
nine hundred and ninety nine let's just
see how this one's gonna turn out this
is this seems like a like a difficult
problem but once again if we just focus
and don't get lost we're going to where
we're going to get the right answer
hopefully
so 1 plus 9 is 10
right the 0 carry the 1.
1 plus 0 plus 9 is 10.
write the 0 carry the 1. 1 plus 0 plus 9
that's 10 again
write the 0 carry the 1.
now 1 plus 9 is 10
plus eight
ten plus eight is eighteen
right the eight
carry the one
one plus nine is ten
plus eight is eighteen
right the eight carry the one one plus a
nine is 10 plus 8 is 18 right the 8
carry the 1.
now we're in the millions place 1 plus 1
million plus 5 million is 6 million plus
6 million is 12 million
write the 2 million and then carry the
1. because 12 million is 2 million plus
10 million
10 million plus 10 million right this is
1 10 million plus another 110 million
right that's 1 plus 1 is 2. and then we
are done fifteen million nine hundred
ninety nine thousand and one plus six
million eight hundred and eighty eight
thousand nine hundred ninety nine is
twenty two million eight hundred and
eighty eight thousand so you know you
just saw we're just doing we're doing
seven and eight digit number editions
but you could apply this if i had a
number with a hundred digits in it you
could do the exact same thing you just
have to go start at the right go each
column by each column and then if you
end up with a two digit answer when you
add the two two-digit when you add the
two one-digit numbers you just carry the
tens place you just keep doing that and
work your way left and if you make no
errors you'll get the right answer